The 29 to
35 to 52 area.
Here you go buddy. Do you feel older? B,
thank you. So I don't get Eddie drunk.
Cause becomes like a Gremlin
when you get water can go wrong.
I love any brown comes and
he's a truly good human beings.
I don't give a fuck and my friend forever.
Yeah,
I like it here a little buzzed.
Fire up this flatter like companion
ladder if the k zero bro. Dude,
how about MLK conspiracies
though? I didn't mean to go
down this road. Mike Baker,
dude, did you hear that? I was humbled.
I watched Mike Bakers and then I
went down a rabbit hole on youtube,
on MLK conspiracy here from the CIA's
convinced that someone helped James Earl
Ray to convince guys legit as fuck.
So when he, when he said, all right,
let me look in. Dot. Here's the thing,
although I like Mike Baker, a great guy.
When I brought up JFK did the
CIA killed JFK. It's like,
you know with his Mlk,
Martin Luther King junior thing.
I know, I know. You seem to know it's
hit things lost credibility. Yeah,
I do believe he was able to pull that off.
And if you get up there,
you can actually pull that out. Any
hundred could do that wrong. No, no, no.
That's not exactly true. You
could do it. It's not that far.
It's less than a hundred yards down. You
haven't, it's a little shaky and the,
and the bullet, the way the
bullet came in telling you the PR,
the only problem is the magic bullet
theory. Okay, here's the risk.
Here's the fight. Here's a fight. Who
was, oh Jesus said he's going to just,
you might as well, I'm not
drinking this. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Who is my birthday man?
I can't have a couple of glasses of wine
talk conspiracy with the chem trails.
It is his birth. I'll fuck. He already
believes that the moon landing is real,
so it is a good point.
Yeah. Yeah. We did just,
I just want to talk a little
concerned with that. Mlk,
what do you think of that be? Cause
you're kind of a government and a half.
The Mike Picker. I liked Mike Baker.
I didn't hear anything about that.
That's later towards the end.
It's one of the last things I wanted to
ask them in the last half hour of the
show. There's a lot of youtube
videos on that by the way. Alan Mlk,
I went down that rabbit. Hold on. That
being a um, you know, conspiracy theory,
that's,
that's just one of the conspiracy theory.
Most like there's a John Lennon one too,
but just MLK for sure.
He was disrupting this.
Uh,
he was bringing people together
in a way that could disrupt power.
Mass is different in body types. This
is really, it's like a before and after.
Well Marcy went to was just a shill.
There's one of those where they,
there's pictures of him
and the Rothschilds and the
Rockefellers were hanging
out. He said he used to have
parties and fucked just white girls.
But I would too if I was him.
That's the way it is.
But that conspiracy theory for sure,
he probably met those people cause the,
for sure they probably wanted to meet him.
It's not like you're either in or you're
out with a group like that. Right.
Those two pictures.
I mentioned youtube videos
on mls given the Promo,
let me hear this.
Let me hear this.